on s'en doutait depuis un certain temps
mais la nasa affirme en avoir maintenant
la preuve il y aurait de l'eau sous
forme liquide sur la planète mars la
sonde de reconnaissance morts or better
aurait détecté de luz forme liquide dans
ses coups les sombres longue de
plusieurs centaines de mètres
elles apparaissent sur les pentes de
nombreux cratères durant l'été martien
et disparaissent lorsque celui ci se
termine ce qu'on se trouve à voir ce
sont des dépôts de sel des chlorates
magnésium et sodium qui se mêle à de
l'eau et qui entraîne le sable et la
boue avec elle donc ça fait ces immenses
traîner il s'agirait en fait d'une eau
extrêmement riche en sel beaucoup plus
que l'eau de mer tellement qu'elle
pourrait rester liquide à des
températures qui atteignent moins 70
degrés celsius d'où vient cette eau on
croit qu'il pourrait y avoir
d'importantes réserves d'eau liquide
dans le sous-sol martien de l'eau qui
remontera à la surface par percolation
puis qui serait absorbée par les dépôts
de sel existe supersonique de la
présence d'eau pourrait favoriser
grandement l'exploration future de la
planète rouge notamment pour la
fabrication de carburant mais également
pour la consommation humaine
si on peut extraire l'eau directement du
sol martien en faisant évaporées ces
sels minéraux ou des choses comme ça on
aurait une source d'eau potable locale
qui diminuerait les coûts de la mission
les risques de la mission la nasa rêve
bien sûr d'envoyer ses astronautes sur
mars mais dans l'immédiat ces objectifs
sont plus modestes qui rit une nouvelle
génération de robots des robots orienté
non plus sur la géologie comme le mars
rover mais vers la détection d'une
possible forme de vie sur la planète
rouge ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal